here are my two favorite strategies for
getting over a breakup number one is
that it takes you as long as you decide
it takes to get over a breakup a lot of
people think that you have to feel
heartbreak in order to honor the
relationship that you were in like if I
immediately start dating right after I
got out of this relationship and it
means that I didn't value the
relationship but why is that true like
why can't I have an amazing relationship
value it and then start dating somebody
the next day it's only a belief it's an
assumption the second thing is I think
that the easiest way to get over
somebody is to find someone better and
so it's not saying that they suck it's
just saying that you guys might suck
together and you can find someone who's
better fit for you and so I think you
should absolutely just get right back on
the horse get back in the hunt and then
realize that there are a lot of fish in
the sea